[Applause]
[Music]
now you
know
[Music]
this is
one of those days so listen today's
podcast is going to do one of two things
to you either your blood pressure is
going to go super high no they got to go
around the doctor because these guys
have a tendency of increasing blood
pressure for people on the right that's
what they their business model some
would say is that I'll read a couple of
their tweets or you're going to sit
there and say you know I like these guys
I like what they have to say but
regardless we're gonna have a good show
Brian and Ed krasenstein Brian is the
one in the yellow
he's a righty okay Ed is the one in the
left in the white he's a lefty right I
want to get these facts right yeah we
got it out there if they were to arm
wrestle who would win who would arm
wrestling I win all the time
now okay so we don't know that this we
will maybe we'll do what he's live I
think it's important for us to figure
out that's really the whole purpose of
today's podcast but we did say if you
said wrestling you didn't even hesitate
yeah you just like I'm gonna take him
out no problem okay so we'll figure this
part out look uh again American twin
brothers who are writers entrepreneurs
and social media personalities they
reside in Fort Myers Florida hopefully
no one's affected because I know the
whole hurricane is kind of coming that
side 50 miles we'll see what happened
there graduated from Rutgers University
the university I think you guys grew up
in Jersey right you guys yeah 2004.
with degrees in economics I think that's
the problem because you went to Rutgers
I Now understand why you guys believe in
what you believe in totally makes sense
they gained Fame during the presidency
of Donald Trump by replying to Trump's
Twitter account very often I think did
you guys ever get blocked by Trump we
did we're actually on a lawsuit to get
unblocked by the Knight Institute I
think it was a knight Institute and he
had to unblock us he had to unblock so
now you're unblocked so the last tweet
he put up the the Moksha that he put up
you could actually see it and respond to
it and then you guys were suspended from
Twitter in 2019 for jet allegedly uh
operating faked accounts you guys deny
the allegations in December 2022 your
accounts were reinstated by the great
Elon Musk yeah fantastic great to have
you guys on the podcast great to be here
so if you don't mind take a minute and
kind of give a little bit about your
backgrounds to I mean I read what's here
but there's obviously a little bit more
to it uh how you guys came about you
know how you all of a sudden you know
through tactics of let me just read a
couple of your tweets so the audience
notes so you guys are this this is a
tweet guys just check your blood
pressure for a second year was this
tweets whatever this is you you can time
it this is a uh Trump being arrested
Tuesday okay so this is going to be the
last few months uh former president
Trump says he will be arrested on
Tuesday Alvin Bragg voland item Hillary
Clinton was never arrested Hunter Biden
was never arrested is it fair to say
lock him up is it fair to say Trump
indictment is justice is it fair to say
that Republicans are wrong is it fair to
say I told you so is it fair to say that
trumpism is a cult if
still support this man Yes exclamation
let me read another one for you okay let
me read another one for you I love the
past yeah
okay next breaking the Secret Service is
closing the White House cocaine
investigation don't get me wrong no one
should have cocaine in the white house
but I find it a bit ridiculous to hold a
press conference about it as if Russia
just nuked New York City imagine if our
president's worried as much about
homelessness mental health uh hate
crimes income inequality and our
national debt as they do this tiny bag
of cocaine right now you know somebody
may say well they got a point over there
anyways I can read a bunch of your
tweets here on what you say tell us how
you guys got started to get your Fame
that you have today on Twitter yeah so I
I mean so we have a business background
uh we ran several businesses uh kind of
jumped back and forth between different
Technologies 3D printing uh AI stuff
like that
2016 uh Trump decided he's going to run
for president uh we didn't like what he
is saying actually our father worked for
Trump for 10 years in Atlantic City we
knew his background we knew kind of how
what did you have a good experience or
bad experience not good or bad I mean
just realist what did your father do for
that he was in charge of marketing for
the Taj Mahal uh and
bankrupt yep he worked there from 1990
to 2000 I then left then they went
bankrupt several years
after that but I like like we had a
firsthand look at like what how he ran
his businesses and how it kind of
devastated the area he screwed over a
lot of contractors so when he decided to
run uh I I thought he was probably going
to be more on the liberal side and and
maybe he was kind of an act that he was
gonna that he was just pretending to be
more conservative
um a lot of the rhetoric I didn't like I
just think he was going to run as a
liberal just it's his background like it
like I mean he he he's pushed for
because he ripped a lot of people off in
real estate
that's an interesting assessment well I
kind of thought because he was so mean
and ripped people off he would run as a
lefty
but like
I was having a son my wife was pregnant
his wife was pregnant uh just by the way
just pure forgive me neither one of you
guys are gay and you're not dead you're
both straight yeah okay I got it my
apologies I thought one of you was I
just want to make sure we get it out
there I mean not nothing wrong with it
nowadays lgbtq gay all that stuff but go
ahead so so like it just it just pissed
me off that like the red arcade is using
a lot of things he is saying I thought
it was divisive uh I it just rubbed me
the wrong way I started tweeting uh fact
checking his tweets and it kind of just
snowballed from there people like what
we were saying and we gained a following
when was it when you're like was there a
moment where you said something that was
picked up or somebody retweeted it you
guys have had some interesting followers
you got a lot of people that follow you
guys a lot of influencers that follow
you guys there was never a moment yeah
it was just like a gradual build up over
time we started replying to his tweets
we kind of figured out the algorithm on
Twitter to make it so our replies would
show up at the top so over time people
would start liking our tweets and
following us and it's just kind of
snowballed so so when did you learn how
to be annoying and like get under
people's skin and I mean by trolling
because trolling is a skill nowadays
right uh for example I think Jake Paul
is a troll to Dana White right I think
there's uh you know he was at least he's
calmed down a little bit the last 12
months certain people there is a like
Takashi 69 he's a troll right I mean if
you go through some of these guys these
guys are you could argue that Elon Musk
is one of the greatest Donald Trump's
the greatest one of the greatest I think
Trump is probably the goat of trolls
there's a business model in trolling I
think that's where you guys really uh
reached Fame you know now you know are
you guys okay with being a label Astros
or does that kind of I would say that
the old crass and science before the
band I think that was more trolling
those there's tweets you read I don't
think they're trolling they're asking
questions starting a conversation yeah
but if you go back to 2018 17 18 19 I
think that a lot of our replies to Trump
that we could get to the top I think you
could definitely consider them why
change though why change it why change
the approach if it worked so I don't
know if it did work I I kind of I mean
it worked in that people started
following it yeah but so we were off of
Twitter for like three and a half years
or so what was the tweet that got you
guys off of Twitter it wasn't a tweet
they they actually said that we bought
our accounts so we we renamed our
accounts we had built up these accounts
we renamed them there was like to like
impeach Donald Trump in Something Else
Like Donald Trump exposed more important
and they thought we bought them what was
the tweet that if you're if you were
trolling Trump for years you didn't get
off Twitter until 2019 you started in
1516 whenever Trump was running what was
the one tweet and finally he's like
enough of these two brother yahoos what
was the tweet that I got it Brian had a
had an Infamous Super Bowl tweet yeah so
it was like I don't know it was like
Rams and somebody playing you'll have to
go back to 2019 or something like that
18 maybe and and I said some of you are
rooting for the Rams some of you are
rooting for the I don't know Giants I'm
here rooting for Robert Mueller and the
rule of law
and it was totally a joke you know but
it pissed off so many people and it went
viral and I think that's how a lot of
people Define it so who were you guys in
high school like if I was in high school
with you who were you guys like if we're
in 10 11 grade one class we're sitting
right next to each other who are you
guys I mean I I wouldn't I think we were
pretty pretty much the average high
school student uh didn't do any sports
didn't I was kind of too small for that
um yeah I don't know I guess maybe like
I make people laugh sometimes because
the reason why I asked that is like if I
think about who Vinnie was I can
visualize who Vinnie was right I can see
how you know in high school he was a 4.6
GPA you know staying close to the
teacher you actually had a very good GPA
but he was he's been a funny guy he's
been a guy that's choke made people
laugh people want to be around when I
think about Adam I remember in sixth
grade when he was teaching the principal
of the school she was 38 years old
station four minutes
sixth grade so it is what it is but
after after class were you guys like the
ones that got under the teacher scan
were you the one that got under the The
Jock the the quarterback that was
leading the way who like what what
dynamic was there any glimpses that we
can look back from 2019 go back to high
school and say now I see it you got to
say there was something I don't think so
like I I really don't really I mean we
joked around a lot like probably some
teachers we got under their skin a
little bit but other teachers they
probably loved us did you get under your
dead skin did you piss off your dad did
Dad ever be like you guys got to knock
this off it's a little too much did you
did you piss I think just us fighting
with each other as kids so that's what
it was yeah so so I have two sons and uh
my two oldest sons are 11 and 9 and they
know how to get under each other's skin
very well and in one video I saw Andrew
and Tristan uh say something publicly
they said we made a decision a long time
ago that we no longer make fun of each
other to get under each other's skin
because it's just doesn't work when was
that moment for you guys or does it
still happen today except it's just in
behind closed doors so our last fist
fight was probably when we were like 23.
uh how long was that like two years ago
yeah because you look 41 now holy
you that's right 2004 Rutgers yeah
you're 41. yeah good for you so 23 was
the last fist fight I think that who won
it who won he locked himself in the
bathroom and I punched a hole
no it was a little more same size you're
locking yourself in a bathroom
or an inch taller he's about two pounds
heavier it's a fair fight basically when
it comes down yeah why are you locking
yourself in a bathroom I got the last
hit and I'm like you know it's over with
the tag you're it yeah pretty much okay
so so tell us your your uh uh how you
came uh to your political ideology that
you have you know how you believe in
what you believe in obviously you know
University got a hold of you early on
Rutgers they're going to give you what
they're going to give you your dad
probably working with Trump and
marketing Taj Mahal 10 years and them
shutting it down and a bunch of people
losing jobs those people who lost jobs
are probably never going to have
anything good to say about Trump but
that happens all the time where people
have to make certain decisions that
happens in the world of business but
what were some of the influences on why
you guys seem to not only dislike but
you can't stand a figure like Donald
Trump so so for me I think half my
family were Republicans other like my
dad's side was were Democrats my mom's
side we're all Republicans I really
didn't care about politics I didn't vote
until Trump Hillary I never voted before
that and I really didn't care about
politics like Obama McCain Obama Romney
I didn't really have too much of a
preference I probably supported Obama I
just probably just because I thought
he's a cool guy but I didn't really have
too much of a political opinion on
things and I think Trump kind of made me
start focusing on politics probably just
because he was such a big character and
somebody who you know had such strong
opinions and I feel like he kind of took
the party in a different direction and
previously I was like okay I'm kind of
moderate I don't really care one way or
the other
I mean these things didn't really affect
me yet you know I was just getting out
of college just moving down here to
Florida so I I think Trump kind of
pushed me
into politics and kind of made me more
left-leaning I would I would say yeah I
mean it's pretty much the same for me
like like my wife was more into it than
I was and like I started paying
attention I think I actually voted for
Obama but I was very like indecisive I I
didn't I mean you were ready to vote for
McCain yeah I mean I I easily could have
seen myself voting for McCain
um I I think from a business standpoint
I was more right-leaning from a social
social issues side I think more left how
much of this is an act like going after
Trump how much of it is an act because
it worked it's effective and you know
how to say this stuff but behind closers
you're like listen man the guy's a
badass you know he's doing what he's
doing he's you know one in business one
in media 15 years show you know
Apprentice he's become a president who
the hell has ever done that in the
history of America where you know maybe
there's some kind of respect for it but
it's an easy target we go after him
right now and that's going to help us
get our eyeballs for the business I'd
say it's not an act definitely not
enough for sure because a lot of people
say they're nah even Kyle Kolinski who
we've had him on before you guys know
Kyle Kelsey uh is it fair to say Kaiser
like a left to East probably I would say
he's left of being a liberal I would say
he's a full-on like social I think so
yeah I think so I is that is autographs
right there behind me yeah I think Kyle
would be somebody that's left of left
yeah and he's pretty hardcore out there
and he's a progressive even he doesn't
know if this is an act because for him
he should sit there and kind of be more
on your side but he's not a fan and he's
a guy on the left of left he thinks he's
an act some other people have said it's
an act if it is an act it's it's worked
very well if it is real then tell me why
it is real like what do you really not
like about this guy I I just think that
like everything that comes out of his
mouth is divisive and and it
the politics aside like I get the
politics I can understand a lot of the
views from the right of you and how they
relate to those on the left it's just
his divisiveness I I feel there's a lot
of like hatred that's being brewed under
what he's saying uh I I think that's the
biggest thing I if if he was less
divisive I I could see myself uh maybe
not voting for another Republican but I
could definitely see myself
understanding them and and at least
considering it so so based on what
you're saying this it's less his
policies it's more approach you don't
like got it so you like his policies you
just don't like him as a person I I
don't like his Republican okay folks we
just made an announcement change the
Wikipedia the Republican Brothers
krasensteins but but Brian how much of
that do you guys think was the media
um you guys are intelligent guys how
much do you think that the media played
a role because I've I've seen it so much
we were talking about earlier how the my
black friends now are turning especially
with all these indictments in the arrest
that are telling me like dude literally
a phone call two days ago when my friend
was like bro I'm talking about Trump
hater drank the Kool-Aid he was selling
the Kool-Aid he was like Vinnie
I smell like I get what you're saying
how much of that do you guys think
played a part because the media bro
they're they're gangsters they know what
they're doing they make people the media
sucks like I'm I'm 100 I think the media
is just as bad and both sides of the
media I think but I feel you know as
president you're not supposed to play
into that and that's I mean some would
say that's Trump's flaw other people
would say that's Trump's strength but I
think the fact that he came out
basically the first day on the campaign
Trail I think calling the media the
Enemy of the State or the enemy the
people but uh but but he also he also
called Democrats that 100 no 100 but but
you know elf in us he was right in the
sense that not only were they fake news
and the enemy of the people which I
think if you if you act the way that
they act and you put out false stories
and 100 of the enemy of the people
and then
before he even got in they were the
whole media in collusion with FBI and
Obama every Hillary everybody at the NC
they're all spying on the guy they're
all trying to like get him out of office
before he got in how pissed off would
that make you be honest you win fair and
square Russian collusion I don't care
when people are still like but there was
ads on Facebook Trump did not need
Facebook and Russia to be Hillary the
most unlikable human being on the planet
wouldn't you be pissed off if you were
him at everybody including the media if
when before you even came in that swamp
was circled around you and everybody was
coming at you yeah I mean but I think
it's kind of like the chicken or the egg
right like who started it who started
throwing the throwing the food at each
other right okay and I think as
president or somebody running for
president I think you have to be bigger
than that I mean and why do you think
why do you say that is it because we're
just Americans just like because we get
screwed over you guys know this every
presidency every government we're
getting it but from what you guys just
say yeah but Americans like to be
coddled and you know even though they're
getting screwed you know they want you
know they want an appetizer but they
want to be taken out to like I would
rather have somebody that just doesn't
sugarcoat anything and it's just right
in your face we're used to the the nice
while we're getting screwed Trump
doesn't do the appetizers or anything
Trump was just in your face and telling
you the truth and I feel like that like
you said we're used to nice kind tell us
what we want to hear Trump didn't have
time for any of that bro he's a
businessman and he was right in our face
yeah and I I think that's why so much of
the country likes Trump and so much this
country dislikes Trump because people
have different ideals of what the
President should be and Trump doesn't
fit into that box for so many people but
he he's that refreshing change for other
people yeah I agree so would you guys
would you guys consider yourself Trump
haters like do you guys hate the guy no
I I don't hate him and like we made this
like when we came back on Twitter we
said it didn't really accomplish
anything when we were trolling him if
you want to call it that I I feel all it
did was make a whole bunch of people in
the right pissed off at us and a whole
bunch of people in the left it just
reinforced their ideas so when we came
back we said hey let's at least create a
dialogue and maybe do things a little
bit differently if Trump comes back and
starts Tweeting or posting on X whatever
you want to call it I I don't think
we're gonna behave the same way as we
did in 2019 I don't think it's it's
gonna accomplish anything if we do has
has your opinion uh about him at all
changed since 2016 on how to Media
treated him how they you know things
they said about him the Durham report
you know even Jake Tapper coming if you
can play the Jake Tapper clip because
you know a lot of times people will say
what about the Durham Port what about
this and what about that and you know
they just don't want to talk about it
but then here's a a clip from Jake
Tapper who is as a you know face of the
left for you know when it comes on to
mainstream media he's got credibility
with the left and here's what he said
and even his panel's pissed off when
he's saying this go ahead and play this
clip
first one is about the Durham you can
play this and then we'll go to the next
one go ahead regardless the report is
now here it has dropped and it might not
have produced everything of what some
Republicans vote for it is regardless
devastating to the FBI and to a degree
it does exonerate Donald Trump
regardless that's Jake Tapper saying
that devastates the FBI it's not like it
hurts the FBI devastates the FBI and
then here's him talking about uh the
deal with Biden's watch this one here
I'm sure you guys have seen this
can we get the audio on this about Joe
Biden from earlier this month
um noting that Hunter bite admitted in
court in July that he was in fact paid
substantial sums from Chinese companies
Kessler wrote Hunter Biden reported
nearly 2.4 million in income in 2017 and
2.2 million in income in 2018. most of
which came from Chinese or Ukrainian
interests but and this directly goes
against what Joe Biden said in the
debate in 2020 uh with uh Donald Trump
take a listen
son has not made money in terms of this
thing about what are you talking about
China why'd you not have that President
he made a fortune in Ukraine in China
so it's from two different debates but I
mean Trump was right I mean he did make
a fortune from China and Joe Biden was
wrong I don't know that he was lying
about it he might not have been told by
Hunter but this blind spot is a problem
it's a problem one because Republicans
aren't going to let it go that's for
sure and by the way so when you watch
this and you see what's happened for
many years a lot of people believe that
something happened with Trump in Russia
including people on the right they're
like maybe something really did happen
with Russia what do we know I don't know
anything if FBI is investigating these
guys are credible sources we better
believe these guys
and then Durham they have to say this
and then Biden he took the money and
says I never he's never taken money from
anybody and I know for your your
argument's going to be well what about
the fact that Kushner did that deal with
this I'm targeting specifically this
argument here has anything with you
changed to say bro like if you guys
are talking with each other brothers
behind closed doors we're kind of wrong
about Russia and this guy we're kind of
wrong about the Biden and that and what
position are we going to take now we
have to kind of be careful on the
approach we take moving forward because
we could lose our credibility or did you
guys and I didn't follow all the process
maybe you guys did you come out and say
look we were kind of wrong about XYZ and
now we're going to move on so like
Russia so I mean you could say that
Trump was right and he was exonerated
which he was right like I mean there
were no charges filed but but you say
there's nothing going on with Trump and
Russia isn't entirely true either I mean
Paul matterford his campaign manager
literally handed campaign data to a
Russian spy and Roger Stone was working
with Wikileaks to get Hillary's emails
releasing Trump specifically asked
Russia to release the email so so I mean
there's definitely questions there right
well and and I don't think Trump
did themselves any favor by the way he
acted and kind of kind of LED those in
the left on and kind of pushed this
Theory uh he was basically calling for
Wikileaks to release the emails he was
firing James Comey in the midst of this
investigation so like
I think it's a combination of yeah there
were some links to me like that gave
more ammo to the other side to say you
see you see it yeah okay I got you okay
and I I mean like so you you had these
actions where he was kind of taji Russia
I mean was it criminal probably not like
I don't think it but brother there's
there's a there's a difference between
you know something where
we have inconclusive evidence that this
guy's he tied to Russia you know your
shift comes out you know and we have
this and yeah later on comes at us from
Hillary do you know how dark that is
like to to say the opponent to be that
level of Darkness Hillary for the 35
million to find anything that was
supporting were on the back end Biden
was the one that his kid was getting
money from Ukraine and Russia but it's
almost as so the question a lot of
people ask on the right is whatever they
do they say you did to put it on you and
it puts all the pressure but the entire
time they were doing it that gets people
who like there's three camps right now
in America let's break down the camps
what are the chances of you voting Trump
in 2024 zero okay what are the chance of
you know others voting for Biden in 2024
Z ero right
we have the camp
put
40 on each side put 45 45 on these I put
whatever number you want on each side 47
44 we've heard about the deplorable you
know we've heard about what all these
comments have been made both sides let's
put them there
is a camp in the middle
some of the center left Dems
Libertarians Independents who are either
gonna
sit there who say things like my voice
doesn't matter like you have a guy here
who I've known for 20 something years he
says what matters if I vote yeah he he
doesn't have an audience to say anything
what he votes or not but if somebody who
has a voice says what the what
difference does it matter for me not to
vote you actually haven't you're
influencing others not to vote right but
for the person that doesn't have any
influence and says what's the difference
with me voting or not voting or you know
what maybe I'm going to be voting I
don't know if I like what Biden's doing
I don't know what Trump is doing this is
kind of weird to the people that are in
the middle who maybe didn't vote for
Trump
who are not Trump people they're sitting
there and they're saying look man like
so so first you do what on this day it
does this then you do this the next day
on this day now man you guys are
targeting like even if you're from that
camp you're either supportive of the
fact that they're targeting him or
you're sitting there saying guys this is
you're crossing the line a little bit
you're almost making me wanna like Trump
I can't believe you're doing this but
you're almost getting a guy like me who
would have never fought him let's just
say people are saying this who would
have never voted from to say I'm going
to support this guy because I think you
guys are shady do you see a part of that
happen in America right now like even
with the whole uh the the mug shot where
you know different rappers are coming
out in support of trump and you're doing
what they did to us and you know some of
the people are sitting there saying you
know names of rappers that would have
never done anything like this who are
now coming up maybe as a followers Chief
Kee for you know Benny The Butcher these
are not like
you know rappers who claim their thugs
these are rappers who are
came from Inglewood and Keith is an
Inglewood guy an office in Inglewood
every time I went to Inglewood my office
not in LA but Inglewood Chicago that was
a interesting place to come out of it
like no we're back in him and we're
doing this up a bunch of guys little
pump these are names that are coming out
supporting him because they're saying we
now relate to you because what they're
doing to you we've been going through
with our justice system for years and
we're feeling your pain and we're going
to come back and support you do you I
kind of see a little bit of weight I
think we've got to wait let's see what
happens let's see if he gets convicted
if he's found not guilty or if he's
exonerated anyway if it you know the
trials you know he gets off anyway I
think yeah I mean that definitely is
going to play a huge Factor but I mean
if he's found guilty in any of the
trials or at least half of them right I
think
it was warranted don't you feel it's a
little weird though that not only the
timing they just they just announced
that he his trial they made it go to the
week before super Tuesday the day before
the day before I apologize the day
before so like like it's it's it's scary
to see how because mind you they're
they're going after him for talking
about cheating which I I saw a clip
yesterday of eight minutes of just
Hillary and everybody in the media
cheating Donald Trump cheated cheated it
just goes on and on and on so he's
basically saying that they cheated in
2020 which I mean we've seen videos of
ballot harvesting and all that stuff
which there was technically there was
cheating meanwhile they're using the
Department of Justice right now to
actively cheat and go after a political
opponent so if like you have to be blind
to see what's happening and I think
people are waking up to the fact it's
like they know that he is way too
popular he's gaining popularity by the
day I just we talked about this before
you guys walked in I don't know what the
left is up to but I don't know if that's
their main thing to not have him run
because he's getting more popular like
do you guys see how they're kind of
using like the Department of Justice to
go after this guy
I I mean if if you think that there's
there's nothing in between there and
Biden's just saying hey mayor Garland
and go after him then yeah but that's
not how it works uh you can have this
theory that there's all these
discussions taking place behind the
scenes but there are separations there's
separations Powers there's the the
courts have to decide hey a judge needs
to sign off on a warrant a subpoena
there's a grand jury there's four
independent grand juries and they've all
indicted him and yeah you can say it's
easy to indict somebody especially if
they're all in the same I mean think
about they're all the
these are all demo
Democrat I think a better question is
this I said you know so imagine you put
four tweets okay and you target John Doe
or you target anybody
exactly 24 hour four hours after those
tweets you all of a sudden get sued you
think there's a pattern there or you
think that's accidental and coincidental
thing that's accidental inquisite
coincidental you're really our man of
Faith you you really believe in you know
uh can you play this video I just sent
you I just want you to watch this here I
mean this is this is just a clip for you
to watch and I I I sincerely want your
real reaction to to this to say no this
was all a coincidence if you can just
play this Origins Community they have
six ways from Sunday at getting back at
you then April 4th the Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg indicts Trump in that hush
money case even
document case July 27th Jack Smith adds
more charges
very next day Jack Smith indicts Trump
for the January 6 case later in the
afternoon or that night and that evening
Fulton County D.A Willis Trump and 18
others in the Georgia 2020 election
probe yet another set of indictors and I
feel great just great profound sadness
that we have a former president who has
been indicted for so many uh charges
that went right to the heart of whether
or not our democracy would survive you
take on the intelligence Community they
have ways from Sunday at getting back at
you okay so Chuck Schumer gave actually
very good counsel right but here's the
question
brother I mean
Brian
five different times
the day something bad news comes about
bidens the next day you have to say
brother that is so bold like you are no
longer holding back and worried about
average people in the public voters to
say that hey guys can you guys make it a
little less obvious you're like I don't
want this drunk guy to win but you're
making a little too obvious that my
friends are saying this I don't really
know what to tell these guys right now
so like flip it around though why are
you saying that so you have the
political side which is going after
Hunter Biden right so they're conducting
all these interviews that they're
conducting investigations they know
about when any indictment is going to
come we knew that defini Willis was
going to come sometime in August
you're saying that the judicial branch
and the court systems are
going after Trump
because this Hunter Biden news is coming
out it's much more likely that the
political side the house is going after
Hunter Biden around the same time to
cover the media coverage of the Trump
indictment so I wouldn't be much more
likely but I'd say I'd say could be
either way like if you're on the left
credibility then because whoever comes
last was intentional not whoever hear me
out like for example if I punch you
first okay okay boom you punch me back
it's a reaction you're waiting if you uh
let's just say all of a sudden get
accused of
if you get accused of stealing money
from me and then the next day you say
but did you see what he did seven years
ago and then it happens again but did
you see this and it happens again it's
the next day they're not even waiting
for a week or two weeks but what if what
if I said I'm gonna punch you tomorrow
and you punch me first no no that's not
oh do you not do not think that Trump's
attorneys are communicating with Kevin
McCarthy in the house stop but you're
look I mean you don't know right you
don't know but what you're saying is
it's so delusional
for example I'll give you an idea
we can talk about NATO and and bricks
and Ukraine and Russia next right
I have a hard time sitting there and
being super supportive of allowing
bricks to do whatever they want to do
and and that's more Democratic position
I may have because it's kind of like
listen man there's three letters and
bricks that you know two letters and
Bricks I'm not comfortable with there's
nobody in you I'm worried about or NATO
I'm worried about if that makes any
sense like who am I worried about in you
Germany they're gonna attack us am I
worried about UK today not that things
could change in the next four 10 15
years a new leader comes in but I'm
worried about China because they hate us
I'm worried about Russia totally get
that right I'm being very reasonable
with you for you guys to you know sit
there and say yeah but turn it around
it's delusional the next day you're
coming out with a summer lawsuit to
Target this guy it shows a lot of
weakness what it does to me being raised
in Iran living there for 10 years
to a mother whose entire family were
communist pretty much and my dad who
were imperialist and I lived in Germany
at a refugee camp for a couple years
I watched this and I'm like yeah
America's becoming a Banana Republic
like many other places and they're using
it to eliminate an audience my friend
called me from Ecuador who was my
groomsmen at my wedding
and you know me did you hear about what
happened here in Ecuador or what
happened the candidate the Republican
candidate two weeks away from election
he's leaving one of his campaigns he
gets in the car three guys shoot him
they kill him
the cops get a hold of one of the guys
they take them back to the police
station and in the police station the
guy somehow dies they should have been
kill him weird wait that's never
happened in America before right of
course no one's ever a guy named Jack
Ruby takes out really Harvey Oswald
before we find out what was really
behind him it's not like that was a big
event that happened in the history of
America no it's just a president getting
assassinated right I mean you can't say
that when it's five times I can though
because you know that Trump's lawyers I
know Trump can't say that because you
want to believe it but if it's truly but
I can say the same thing about you
though so listen are you saying that
Trump's attorneys didn't have a good
inclination of when he was going to be
indicted or when these different things
were coming down he was tweeting about
it he was tweeting I I'm gonna be
indicted tomorrow you know what a bold
gangster does do you know what a bold
youngster how does a bold gangster kill
somebody I don't know you tell me in a
public daylight and for like an American
Gangster you ever seen a movie American
Gangster yeah do you remember the scene
he's at the coffee shop with his cousins
and they're all sitting there and a guy
he sees that's on the other side that
didn't pay his money he goes up to him
and it's played by the good-looking guy
Idris I don't know his uh elbow what's
his last name yeah good looking guy and
he goes up to him and says hey I thought
you were going to pay me my tax ten
percent I didn't get any of the money he
starts laughing in his face in daylight
he grabs the gun boom boom shoots him
put some cash goes back and has
breakfast and fix the sugar puts it back
the left
what they're doing today the closest
thing I can see to them is what Frank
Lucas said in daylight they don't give a
they want everybody to know UF with
us the intelligence Community sponsored
by Chuck Schumer we're gonna publicly
intentionally do it and you can't say
nothing about it but here's a problem
there's a big problem with this Brian
Annette
short term Frank Lucas was a star
long-term friend Lucas eventually gets
caught and arrested but sometimes it
takes a few years for Frank Lucas to
have a lot of power in the streets and
that's kind of what they got today
they're not going to have this forever
life doesn't work this way God's a
powerful God and men and women of Faith
who believe in the powerful
organizations like the doj or the mob
who try to bully regular people for a
certain period you can do it eventually
the real people of value who don't like
tolerating stuff like this stand up and
say yeah it's too much your bullying
people we're not okay with it you can do
this to this guy Donald Trump he's going
to come and go but America is bigger
than just one person you cannot ever do
something like this again to put the
fear you know how many people friends
that I know that I'd love them to run
for office I had a conversation
yesterday with a guy at 11 30 I know you
know who this guy is
he's from the left
and he can't stand Donald Trump we had a
very good conversation together very
good
you know how many people
that love America who want to run for
office they're not running you know why
they're not running because all they're
seen is man I don't want them to do to
us what they did to Trump yeah I mean
that that's fair right but I mean I feel
like you're stating this as this is
what's happening and I don't I don't
know it's like right five times not once
or twice or three times but like but if
you listen to the left they're saying
the opposite right you're saying they're
the Comer's pushing out all this stuff
well but I mean it's is it possible tell
me do you think it's possible that's not
it's not possible it's not possible no
because that's not how this works the
way this works is what she do the day
after okay what she do today any kind of
bad news that comes out against Hunter
Biden the day after they target Trump
the day after like it is so bold it
ain't even funny how bold they are Trump
is such an expert at getting ahead of
the media cycle like he's done that his
whole career whether it was in business
whether it was when he's president wait
you think Trump trump won once Hunter
Biden the news about Hunter Biden to be
the top of the news cycle and then his
stuff comes on the bottom and he's like
it's what he's done his entire life wait
go look at our last 20 podcasts check to
see how many times we talk about Hunter
Biden I don't care talk about Hunter
Biden yeah you know why I don't talk
about home Biden you're going to catch
him how often do I talk about Hunter
Biden how often in this podcast do we
talk about 100 I don't think I might
most often the thing we're talking about
not even it's not top 10. and he's a guy
that voted for Biden publicly I give a
thousand dollars to this guy on a
podcast I said he was going to win
that's where you voted for him as well
correct yeah took a lot of money because
I played with Vegas but but you also
voted so there's money and you voted the
point I'm making to you is this is a guy
that was abiding the supporter he's not
a trump guy I would just say I voted for
him I wouldn't say I was a supporter
just like if I'm voting is supporter
just like if I vote for Trump this time
I'm not a trump supporter I mean
technically you are you're supporting
the guys I'm not going to even you're
going to be voting against the other
times
let me explain that is a form of
supporting it's in English like if I go
to Starbucks over 7-Eleven you're
supporting they both suck I support
Starbucks that's how this works okay so
let me go back to the point I'm trying
to make to you is I don't care to talk
about Hunter Biden
I don't care if they talk about Hunter
bite if it's going to happen it's going
to happen go ahead and talk about you
know oh my god look what happened over
here that's not our show we're regular
people who have families have lives we
have different lives that we live all
three of us but even Tom that's here
Tom's in a very different life that he
lives than these guys live He's living a
different life way different than the
life he's living way different than
their lifetimes living way different
than the life I'm living
um but for us when you do that five
times in or the average person sits
there even from your side who voted for
Biden even those they say it's a little
fishy man it's a little fishing when
you're doing this I mean Schumer said
don't do it you did it now they're
coming after you they'll ruin your life
so going back to it
so many guys
that ought to consider running don't
want to run because the spectacle of
what they did the last six years they
stole the guy's life so when he became a
president he couldn't do anything for
the first three years because it was
Russia he couldn't do anything to last a
year because it was covet the first
three years it was all Russia nobody
believed him the last year was coveted
he's the worst person of all time you
realize they literally stole four years
of him being able to do anything doesn't
that happen with every president no I
mean that's like that not at that level
yeah I'd say go to Obama I'd say Biden
Obama yeah
Obama every news station Colbert and
Obama you know Leno when he was still on
or you got camel Fallon MSN worship ABC
this is the greatest president of all
look I got a Nobel Prize the day you
know nothing they've painted him as the
greatest president of all time and tried
to even
doing anything and everybody was
supposed to just sit down bow down to
this guy being the greatest of all time
and we took it yeah like so before but
before Trump that's how things were but
apparently now things are changing
because but but ask the question why do
you realize what was the most
humiliating a moment of uh by Obama's uh
presidential run what was the most
embarrassing moment of Obama's run when
he uh made the white house uh do the
flag no the LGBT flag well that was
pretty interesting that was pretty
interesting I don't think that was the
most individually not not as a country
we looked embarrassing as a country but
as an individual
khaki pants won that one time I actually
right people flipping out they were
attacked
let me just say this point just so just
so you asked me about this guy I think
he's a guy I would be totally cool
having dinner with I think we'd have fun
talking Sports I think we'd have fun
talking politics I think I would like
sitting down with this guy and enjoying
the show with him okay Obama when I
watched them on different shows I liked
watching them it wasn't like I don't
like watching them what was the most
embarrassing woman of his career when he
was a president when he was doing the
Fallon or the Kimmel show and is reading
all the tweets and he reads this tweet
and he says you know President Obama may
go down as the single worst president in
a history of America something like that
and then what does he do he grabs the
phone he says oh yeah at least I will go
down as the president the president any
attitude and he drops his phone right
okay and then what happens at the dinner
where he's making fun of Donald Trump
he'll never win
you know how competition Works discussed
from streets of Chicago Obama is very
competitive do you think out of the 7.7
billion people around the world if there
was one person he was not okay with
becoming the president you know who it
was only one guy and the guy he didn't
want one and then later on Obama gate
comes worse than Watergate where Glenn
Greenwald just a few days ago here
explained how much worse Obama gate was
spying on Trump's campaign for Trump to
win and then he has to live that for the
rest of his life yeah no so what happens
there everybody in media that loved him
and who were close to him speculation
this is my speculation hey guys he
humiliated our favorite President of all
time Barack Obama we got to Target this
guy and ruin his life and ruin his life
they did now he's Teflon so he can
handle it but ruin his life they did and
then four years later covet excellent
opportunity they used to kick him out
and boom now they're arresting the guy
every other day and what a great
strategy these guys use brilliant but
all of it goes back to this and and a
guy named Barack Obama I'm Brian Ed uh
just out of here and I hate now that we
brought him up I have to talk about it
the hunter laptop okay laptops because
he left a couple at that place we found
out this year with the Twitter the
Twitter files that and this is I don't
care how you spin it this is cheating
that there was so much information on
there about him his father the big guy
all these deals that the FBI in
conjunction colluded with Twitter and
all these social media places to stop
that storage and suppress the story
anybody that tweeted about it anybody
that spoke about it you were taken off
uh all these platforms that is actively
cheating to help one political party so
no matter what anybody says that 100
affected and they did a poll Pat of
Voters and they said if you knew what
was on this laptop and all the that
was with him and his father would it
have swayed your vote and what was it
like 40 were like yeah we probably would
have we wouldn't have voted for him so
at the end of the day from the Russia
collusion to all this to the laptop that
system that he's talking about oh 53 of
Americans made aware of the 100 body
laptop story would have changed their
vote so guys be on let's just let's be
men about this that isn't cheating for
you that it is that cheated so I I
disagreed with the fact that Twitter
deleted that New York Post article I I
think that was wrong do you call it but
hold on you call it cheating I wouldn't
say it's cheating because Twitter acted
as a private company Twitter did not act
at the behest of the FBI they may have
been they were there they were actively
going there telling them we're with the
FBI
this story out because it'll help a
political candidate but that's not
that's not what FBI told Twitter yes
they did like did you read the Twitter
files of course we did they said it was
misinformation and Twitter decided based
on what FBI so how's it Mrs Holland so
if the FBI if
so that's the FBI the same FBI that said
the dragons to this Russian collusion
they say that if there's
characteristics they know come on
the letter said there is characteristics
of Russian disinformation
which are arguably it could have been
right well so I mean so uh are you
joking right now no I'm telling you what
happened I I actually want to leave you
to speak and I want to be yeah and I
want to hear you so are you sincerely
being serious about what you're I'm just
telling you what they said no no I
understand that but you're saying it in
a way
I disagree 100 with the fact that
Twitter removed that article okay 100 so
then if they would have kept it 53 said
that would have changed it the way they
would have voted that could have meant
the difference of trump being president
versus Biden yes yes it could have yes
and I think what Twitter did was
absolutely I don't think it was I don't
think they the idea that the FBI forced
them to remove it they didn't that the
FBI has Donald Trump himself asked
Twitter to remove tweets from Twitter
right is is that so is that an election
interference too I mean stay on this
topic here yeah stay on the topic here
so
you just said yes it would have uh
changed the um I don't know if it would
have changed yes no I mean you guys are
if there's you guys are smart guys you
know you're not you're not guys that are
dumb guys you guys are smart guys so if
you're smart just be the smart guy that
you are
so
if that is the case so now watch this
do you know when you when you think
about in sports when somebody wins with
a method of cheating okay there was a
guy who was a guy that was fighting and
at the end this other guy ended up being
paralyzed he ended up dying the guy had
at the end of the fight the father have
you guys seen this video it's a very
emotional video where the father comes
in and at the end of the fight the
father who's the trainer grabs the
opponent's hand and he starts doing this
to the to the gloves he does this to the
gloves because he saw what they did to
his face
and then he says he calls it and the
guy's like no no he starts have you ever
seen this clip or not he has he had
people you have to find this video right
and let me tell you they find the gloves
they open it up no and in the gloves
there was metal and rocks
either like it is the most my body just
got there I just got chills all of my
body you have to watch this video it's
so freaking hard to watch I'll find it
out when I'll respond back to them I'll
find out I'll send it to you
this kid for the rest of his life lived
out of a uh wheelchair it was paralyzed
for life I mean that guy cheated ruined
his life so imagine
the rage on half of America who were
publicly humiliated for losing who
supported a guy that they wanted to go
again and covet heard him and not only
that that tweet hurt him in their eyes
he should be the president and now this
guy deserves another four years in their
eyes now you're doing this again five
times in a row the day after with
knowing the fact that Hunter Biden's
taking money knowing the fact that in
the history of the White House if
there's ever been cocaine there I don't
know how much cocaine Lincoln did at the
White House but there's not a lot of
research on him COC came back in the
days so cocaine's only going to be
linked to one guy now we're supposed to
say nah it's not going to be him it's
probably somebody else honestly it's
probably Donald Trump Jr somehow did
cooking and left that's probably him we
have to
you realize how the American people feel
like why do you talk to us like we're
dumb and stupid at this point I'm okay
with buying some propagandas you want to
sell but the moment you start looking at
me as I'm stupid the voters like I'm
sick of you treating me like I'm an
idiot I'm not an idiot I know what
you're doing and you can't win so that's
the rage the fact that even a guy like
yourself said that could have influenced
it yeah I mean the left is probably
outraged as well that the Republicans
are talking about and teaching Joe Biden
right like and they feel the same way
about that they feel like the
Republicans are well I mean you had to
look at it from that point of view as
well right I I but but again
you you
what you're saying is the left is also
by the way I'm not supportive of either
one of them impeaching anybody just just
go do your thing unless if it's like so
this impeaching game is not a game I
support I don't I've not one time
talking to you about them in Peach and
Biden not one time on our podcast it's
not an article I'm interested in I'm not
interested in that kind of stuff that's
going to make this country the greatest
country in the world the shittiest
country in the world we're going to join
a bunch of different people yeah but
this is a cause of they impeach Trump
how many times twice and what happened
nothing yeah did anybody expect anything
else but why did they do it yeah I mean
I don't know yeah
he ate the guy yeah that's the only
reason you do it yeah it's a political
tool well then guess what so if the
right is sitting here right now they're
doing it it's caused it was stemmed by
the left
you started it like this whole thing you
could say the Clinton impeachment
started it too
the Clinton impeachment I'm also not
supportive of that with the Clinton
impeachment what happened there if you
impeached him you want to go impeach all
the other however many presidents that
we got to go back and do that with no
I'm not supportive of that but this one
that one at least there was a proof he
came out and said I did not have and
then he says I have to apologize and
then boom and then it is what it is
obviously in today's climate that would
be a regular day on a Tuesdays
Administration yeah well can I can I I
guess add to the conversation maybe
we'll uh you know by the way if we were
having this conversation one year from
now this is a cute conversation I would
tell you know we're sort of getting
along by the way fast forward a year
from now you guys you talked about
fighting and arm wrestling would be
gone down because the the the
temperature in the room is is that a
very you know comfortable 72 right now
go to August September of 2024 it's
going about to be 98 Degrees and about
to be 104 degrees because it's going to
get very very heated so you know we're
having this conversation but
you know Justin Timberlake used to say
he sang the song like what goes around
comes around what goes around that
that's exactly what's happening in
politics yeah and and no matter what
conversation we have no matter what
happens here's what I can guarantee to
everybody out there every four to eight
years get ready for a new president get
ready for Republican president get ready
for Democratic president why is that
just look at the proof the proof is in
the pudding every four to eight years
America basically has a bipolar episode
and says well
you know those guys suck let's try the
other side well you know those guys suck
let's try the other side you talk about
Clinton and uh basically his uh term
came up in 2000 and that you know Gore
Bush they flipped on um
Clinton they went to gore um they went
to Bush and that was a whole election
fraudulent Chad's ballots everything's
going on then you have everything that
happened with
John Kerry and then it became Obama and
then it became McCain and then it became
the bushes and then it became this and
that we're just used to this right now
we know this thing by now but it did get
uglier under Trump where am I going with
all this here's what we do know for a
fact how many how many people live in
America 300 and some 30 million yeah how
many people vote
150 million it's almost half the country
let's say
what if I were to tell you how many
people do you think run this country
what's your number like how many people
run this country
and I don't mean like the oligarch
Social Media Tech how many people sway
the votes of this country every four to
eight years what's your number I I it's
probably under under 500 I think 500
people
no no but you're not but you're not
asking a question is saying out of the
150 million voters what percentage of
like the left or right independent what
percentage weighs to you how many people
this isn't a trick question it's like
small percentage I would say there's 50
to 100 000 people in this country that
sway the entire electorate of this
country okay so who am I talking about
the people in Fulton County Georgia in
in uh in uh Arizona everything that
going on there in Arizona certain State
uh counties in Wisconsin Michigan
um Ohio even Pennsylvania like the
entire country is basically at the whims
of the same people that voted for Obama
then voted for Trump then voted for
Biden and we'll wait to be seen what
they end up doing in 2024. these people
run the country so you know Pat hit the
nail on the head that you know whether
you call it 45 and 47 or 48 and 42 90 of
the country has their mind up
congratulations good for you there's
zero percent chance that no matter what
evidence anybody shows you you're not
voting for Trump straight up yes yeah no
matter what anybody shows Vinnie there's
a very very high likelihood there's no
chance he's going being provided correct
100 there you go my vote is completely
for sale at this point I am one of those
100 000 people being like yeah uh wasn't
a trump guy Biden's a mess Trump's
indictment I don't know I could flip my
vote I'm one million percent would you
vote third party though no because it's
a wasted vote so I I'm truly one of
those people being like don't Trump
don't like Trump's personality
whatsoever but policies kind of are
better and then you have Biden it's like
yeah these policies kind of suck but at
least it's not Nails on a charger
walking vegetable but he's also my vote
is important in Florida what's my point
with all this kind of stuff like that
you know there's certain people on the
left that have Trump derangement
syndrome straight up there's certain
people on the right where you've
proclaimed that these people are part of
a cult
no for the record I don't I don't
consider them a cult but you
it was a question okay well all right
sorry I I really I really don't believe
that they're both maybe there's ten
percent of the country that are free
thinkers
like you you said that some of your
family is Democrats some of your
families are broken in my household my
mom no matter what I tell this woman
there's a zero percent chance she's
voting for Trump zero no matter I'm like
it's Trump or a ham sandwich he's like
well I don't really eat ham but okay I
guess whatever I tell my sister whatever
she finds out
she's 100 voting for Trump why because
she met him once so but that ultimately
what is happening in this country is
just because someone votes for the other
option this binary option
we don't need to hate our neighbors or
hate our family and that's where we're
at in this country is that if you voted
for the other side you're the enemy and
it's emblematic of where we are and it's
only getting worse so I guess you know
Kyle kolinsky I don't remember we have
that clip
he hates you guys because you're more
left than him okay and there's you hate
Trump because he's
supposedly a liberal now he's you know a
conservative what have him ultimately my
thing is do we really end up need to
hating our neighbors because they vote
for a different
side of the eye no it's absurd like half
my friends probably more than half my
friends are Trump supporters so yeah I
mean I think it's ridiculous that what
the country has come to and how many
friends have you lost because you've
been anti-trump none that I'm aware of
no that's not true no seriously I don't
think I've lost a single friend well
then you're the anomaly because there's
a lot of people out there that will not
be friends with the other side and then
just to Pat's point that the political
motivation about like all right uh news
comes out about that whole thing about
May 5th May 6 May 7th everything with
that how would you describe that
everything just basically the The
Smoking Gun sort of analogy that anytime
there's bad news they'll they'll
basically indict Trump guys
it's true just look at the like
sometimes it's right in front of your
face so are things politically motivated
yes so so apartment weaponized I'm
willing to wait I'm willing to wait and
see what the outcome of the trial is
like I don't think I should be taking
sides either way like you've already
taken your side no no but what I'm
saying is I don't know if Trump's guilty
I don't know maybe it is politically
motivated I don't know I I can see both
sides like you know where Patrick here
says that the doj is releasing these
indictments because yeah but
so you don't give a about evidence
either just Vinnie like I do like you
don't give it no you don't well not
because not for the election I wouldn't
change my vote yeah so that's my point
that's where at in this country you have
you're just clinging to your beliefs
there's no evidence no facts that will
help you sway your vote and that's fine
that's on you do your vote but to me
that's an emblematic of where we are if
someone says by the way the Russian
thing was all a hoax by the way
it was all fraud by the way the justice
department was all weaponized by the way
all the information that you've used to
surmise your opinion is all false here's
the here's the actual evidence you're
like yeah I don't care I'm still going
to vote no so so you're voting that's
not that's not that's it that's not
necessarily true like you just said no
so you're Ed yeah but here you just said
there was a zero percent chance that
you're voting for Trump voting for Trump
but but that's not that doesn't
necessarily mean of it for Biden though
so I could just sit the election out I
mean or vote third party just to make a
point that's weak though well I mean I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna vote for
somebody I think is a bad president
right so so just just because he's found
to be not guilty doesn't mean that that
changes my mind on whether I think he
should be president there's other
reasons
I mean just just policies his
divisiveness I I mean before he was
indicted I wouldn't haven't I wouldn't
have voted for him but but you did say
at the beginning of the podcast I wrote
it down you said you know uh uh approach
versus policies you liked some of his
policies but some of his policies it's
his approach you don't like it's because
of his exposure you're not going to vote
for him that that's a that's a big part
of it there are I prefer the liberal
policies everything which kind of
divisiveness do you do you like less
public or private divisiveness uh Define
each I tell you to your face I don't
like you
versus I tell you to your face I like
you so much but I go behind your back
and tell everybody how much of a
whatever you are which one do you
respect more I I respect I respect the
public I do as well right yeah that's
that's what half the American people
respect half-american people
uh uh kind of respect the fact that he's
not telling you something publicly and
you know if he doesn't like somebody
he's going to tell you we as Americans
uh of for whatever reason
you know as an immigrant myself who
can't hear from another place we're
super skeptical
super skeptical uh and and for me I
think Jay-Z said best in one of his
songs says don't tell me what somebody
said about me tell me why that person
was so comfortable to tell you what they
said about me right okay
I I I respect the guy you know they used
to say 10 15 years ago they said no one
from New York America is not ready for
president from New York and this wasn't
even with uh Trump this was pre-trump
somebody from New York was running
I don't know if it was Christy that ran
before Trump there was somebody from New
York running and saying America is not
ready for New York president because the
way people are in New York is just too
much you know you're from Jersey so you
kind of know the style of New York I
mean Giuliani I guess you know what it
could have been Giuliani that's the yeah
it could have been Giuliani yeah and
then but today's I think Americans with
social media are kind of like you know
what man I must much rather prefer a
straight up guy that's going to tell me
how he feels then the fake stuff because
what social media did is just 20 years
ago 30 years ago a lot of this stuff
would have gotten away and
people like us we couldn't have created
content to just talk to regular people
about our concerns we just had to listen
to those five six different channels
right social media
actually got
some of the American people to say I
prefer a guy that's going to be straight
up with me than the guy that's being
deceiving me or divisive so yeah I mean
I can understand your point about being
divisive but man we gotta yeah no no I I
agree like like I I will say I respect
him speaking his mind right like like
that's fine I think that just some of
the wording he uses and the things he
says can divide us and he could say it a
different way I don't know if I disagree
I I don't know if I'm in a city or say
oh you're wrong and all this stuff I
totally get it that's his wiring you
know how uh when Republicans say stuff
like you know if he would only stop them
who are you to tell him he's going to
change at 74 now 70 what is he 77 or 17
how old is he right now I don't know do
you think he's going to change now now
are they changing this guy so either you
have to take him for who he is are you
ain't changing no 77 year old guy right
so I get what you're saying that maybe
some of his words he says could you know
divide into all this stuff let's
transition to a different place can I
bring up one little thing that you just
said and I think it's very important
because you know we are five dudes
sitting around having a podcast men are
way more comfortable
bring the straight up facts here's the
deal Vinnie you look like
today thanks Adam all right you're good
I appreciate it if you tell a girl that
she will lose her mind of course the
truth okay the truth hurts and that's
why you know they say facts don't care
about your feelings men are a lot more
comfortable hearing you know the tough
news the tough pill to swallow like
would you how do you position the
question would you rather hear the uh
tough news behind your back or in front
of your face how did you add you word it
pat
okay so men are comfortable with that
that's why by an overwhelm Ed margin you
know
you know vote for Trump right whereas
most women cannot take the gold hard
truth right and they will you know
not want to hear the bad news you know
the whole thing with Trump was what do
you you know the the economy is going to
inflation's falling apart gas
prices you know Afghanistan everything
you want to put Ukraine everything order
but no more Mean Tweets
so yeah
rhetoric is is really the the biggest
problem especially for women I I don't
know if that's the majority of the
reason why women don't vote for him I
think there's other reasons too like
abortion and the his Trump's comment
about grabbing women and you know like I
think there's other things at play there
too but most people get my personality
not policies yeah most people would you
agree yeah I would and they just can't
handle his personality and a lot of
people can't I get it I totally
understand but I mean Biden doesn't have
a personality zero she doesn't even know
what he doesn't even know what the hell
he is would you acknowledge the only
reason that Biden got elected was
because not Trump yeah okay absolutely
nobody's rallying for Biden yeah he's
he's beatable he's vulnerable nobody
nobody's nobody has Biden side nobody's
excited about by zero it's just you've
got 30 35 of the country that is
obsessed with Trump nobody has that
candidacy nobody has that and you have
50 of the country that's like yeah I
hate that guy and
it's a law of large numbers right so
Trump brings people to the polls that's
why we feel two record-breaking election
two record-breaking candidates you know
all because of trump yeah everyone's in
the GOP uh debates and it was almost
like wait the main Fighters not here
like we were just watching undercards
and it was it was cool to watch but I
was just like it missed like you got
like that personality now Pat you're
gonna if you're gonna go to someone I
just wanted to ask do you guys think
we would be where we are today with all
the I mean crime is ridiculous the
border gun violence inflation recession
and at the end of the day do you guys
think the Russia situation would be
happening because if Trump was this
Russian asset he he's Putin's I we
heard all that does any of that happen
like he waited for Biden to come in to
Putin to do his attack and everything
you guys think and would that would
Trump's presidency have changed any of
that I you know I it's hard to say I
don't know what Trump would have done
what do you have just said residing with
Putin like we're not going to get
involved and let Putin take more
Ukrainian land I mean he didn't really
do much on Crimea right so I don't know
it could have gone
many different ways well yeah yeah like
maybe there would be other concessions
and maybe Putin wouldn't have invaded
yet you know it's it's hard to say it's
hard but but it's weird though that
nothing happened we didn't hear nothing
about I mean we heard Russia obviously
but nothing happened while he was in and
then once Biden was in it was like hey
it's attack time you know what I mean
yeah but I mean you one could also argue
that Trump was kind of
kind of siding with Putin on a lot of
issues so why would Putin do it then why
not wait until another president came
along like if Putin went into Ukraine
we don't know how Trump would have
reacted and I don't think Putin would
either right like I don't think you know
it's it's it was I think Trump had that
had that indecisive I don't want to say
indecisive indecisiveness like
volatility yeah I think that scared a
lot of people a lot of other leaders of
course so what about everything else so
what about the border and inflation and
it's I mean we're we're a completely
different country that we were so so the
borders so the Border I think a lot of
trump again it goes back to Trump's
volatility and Trump's
Trump's policies of kind of you know we
had the separation of children from
parents we had uh Trump basically
threatening them in with words I think
that scared immigrants away I think and
now now we have good influx don't come
yeah so we are from legal age well so
what I'm saying is I don't have room for
you I think he's scared them by go to
your Sanctuary cities
next the remaining Mexico policy I think
that you know kept people down there I
women were raped because of it but it's
scared and they're like we're not going
to attempt to bring our kids here we
might get separated from them we might
get smuggled by other individuals
I mean I'm with Adam in the sense that
my family came here legally Pat's family
came here legally I understand we are a
nation of open arms and everything but I
mean there's a right way and there's and
there's a wrong way just literally
saying just come ever come on in we
don't yeah you know it's not like that
right now
so the border the border is as secure as
it was in Trump under Trump except for
the fact that they don't have to remain
in Mexico policy can you name it one
policy that's different or one
initiative that's going well I've been
seeing well all the hearings of my orcas
and all the charts and all the stats is
that it's at record numbers right now
and the people coming and dropping off
kids like the grown men that are
bringing children to the Border they're
doing DNA tests there's zero relation to
these children that they're coming and
it's in the like thirty thousand forty
thousand children that that I mean Trump
was at least trying you know I mean
everything was against them everybody's
like no the hell with you leave it open
leave it open leave it open I just saw
another video I don't know if it was an
Arizona Pat or Texas they've not only
opened the border wall they've like uh
welders have gone there and they've
opened it to where you it's not even
going too close they're still building
portions of the wall yeah I mean the
issue with immigration isn't the fact
that we have open borders these are not
technically more open than under Trump
the issue is that people feel like they
have a better opportunity to come here
now that they're not going to be turned
down their kids aren't going to be
separated from them they're not going to
have to remain in Mexico and worry about
what could happen down there so I think
that's a huge difference and that's why
we're seeing what we're seeing right now
well and and like you said you're an
immigrant and you're like my family yeah
so like I know a lot of people who came
here years ago and they're like they're
the same as you they're saying I came
here legally like why should we be
letting these people in and I agree I
think we definitely need to do something
what that solution is I don't think it's
build a wall I I think you have
everybody on the right saying build a
wall and don't really have any other
Solutions and everybody on the left
saying don't build the wall and then
nobody's actually talking about the
actual solutions that could happen that
could actually stop some of this yeah I
just the common sense thing that a lot
of people would ask is who's more
important
America or a politician
America okay if Nancy Pelosi can have a
world around their house I think we can
have a board around our country that's
bringing drugs in isn't that a common
sense question well I mean having a wall
around your house is different than
having a wall and a public land how are
you afraid of people breaking into your
house why do you need to put a wall up
it's it's comparing apples to oranges
tell me why apples and oranges I'm
confused so you're it's a private versus
public first of all how can you build a
wall America is a private country that
you have to come here legally yeah it's
a private country it's a private
property to to United States of America
most of the not most but a good portion
of the people that actually come here
are just oversized but that's not how
you don't sit there and you judge it and
say good portion where is fentanyl
coming from yeah but the Wall's not
going to stop fentanyl the vast majority
of fentanyl is coming through right
people are driving it you don't you
don't you don't you don't build things a
wall around your house doesn't
necessarily protect the robber from
coming into your house I can come with a
drone and see what you're doing there's
plenty of ways of doing it but it
minimizes the chances and it decreases
is you having a gun in your house and
putting a sign outside saying there's a
massive pit bull here and seven AK-47s
if you walk into my house that's going
to minimize the chance of Robert coming
in but maybe one percent the guy's gonna
say I don't give a I'm still coming
in anyways I want to kill your dog and
you're not going to have enough time to
get your guns and I'm going to get the
money
it's about the people feeling safer and
protecting our homeland when fauci and
others are being asked about who has to
take the vaccine if illegal immigrants
are coming here are they expected to
take the vaccine and the answer is no
but we have to the military and all
these guys working for the government do
you realize like how ludicrous that
sounds when they do things like that
that's that's when that's when a person
again like the same question with
Ukraine
you got all the stuff that's going on
with and nothing I'm saying is out of
the ordinary and I'm using like
technical policies I'm just purely
talking Common Sense we got Ukraine that
we want to send more money to now again
uh but Maui 700 bucks a person maybe a
few million dollars these are things
where the average per again the average
person the average person the average
not the person that studies every single
thing there the average person says why
would you spend more money to Ukraine
than to Maui why would we not protect
our borders to take care of us why would
we protect the borders of Ukraine
against Russia but not our own borders
isn't that kind of stupid why these are
these are the basic objections that an
average American is going to ask and the
argument is a lost we don't need a
border at Canada because we don't have a
lot of stuff that's coming out from
Canada
we have so much of that's just a false
equivalency I feel like people jump to
these comparisons that really don't
compare so Mali 700 per per person who
lost their home first household yeah
yeah but I mean that's just what the
FEMA maximum is that's what the FEMA
maximum has been it's actually increased
under Biden I think it went from 500 to
700 so I mean it's a FEMA maximum for
instant money yeah they can they're
going to get more money they just had to
go through an application product the
question the question then becomes how
soon do you need help
instead of going to vacation where
you're like hey you know no comment a
president says no comment about the
biggest devastating event that took
place in Hawaii and you say no comment
and you show up two weeks later and
people are flipping you off and saying
go back home but do you want did you
want him to go there sooner like like so
I I went through Ian last year like
Direct Hit right and when Biden came in
seven days later it was it was chaos
everybody's running around getting
supplies everybody's trying to rebuild
their homes and it shuts traffic I
understand I I understand like you know
100 defending that this guy you know
everything you say you're gonna have to
defend the position I get that position
the more you take a position like that
the more you lose credit no like like
you said no comment that was ridiculous
what should he should have said
something much more compassionate than
that like there's so much but I feel
like people jump at every little thing
and it happens on both just like Trump
Democrats jumped at every little thing
level though I don't know I'm pretty
sure it is I don't think it is you're
coming from the right but you're coming
from the right so that's your
perspective but I'm coming from America
is more important than Ukraine American
borders are more important than other
people's borders it doesn't mean we
can't do both right okay you're saying
the Nikki Haley message which you you
just gave her something yeah exactly
said that so we do but we can do both no
I mean America isn't just no um no no no
no no I'm sorry no no it's not we can do
both no how many kids do you have two
who's more important to your kids or my
kids they're both equally as important
than they
if they were not I would think you have
mental issues okay now but but if you
zoom out no you ask don't do a party no
don't zoom out stay on you stay on you
trust me for me
I am safer if your number one priority
is your kids because your kids are going
to be raised properly with the right
attention by who their father which is
you you're very important man in their
lives you know that that's how this
works so when Nikki Haley says something
like that you know what that message
says to voter like me and by the way
just so you know how I put Nikki Haley I
thought she was going to be the worst in
debate you know what I ranked during the
debate number two I put her at number
two I thought she crushed it to me I was
dumb like dude she killed it I was not
expecting to be like coming out
supportive of uh Nikki I thought she did
a great job right doesn't mean I you
know I'm agreeing with everything she
says but to say we can't do both okay
well let's unpack that a little bit
maybe we can do both
like you know how uh you know one of the
guys broke down things from me
financially which made a lot of sense it
was this girl that wrote a book 20 years
ago with a pig I forgot what the book
I'd love to give her credit 23 years ago
and the way she taught kids about money
it was 70 percent to your expenses
whatever you're doing ten percent
savings 10 Investments 10 fun okay okay
so guess what the fund account do
whatever you want to do with it it's
kind of never thought about having a fun
account right so the way you run a
business same way you know you you use a
certain portion of your money to have a
good time with your employees with your
sales piece you're having fun all that
stuff we talked about it the other day
what kind of overdue to go to Top Golf
you know I don't know what we were
talking about this we were somewhere
yeah
so so to me yeah let's use that money to
support others when they're going
through it after getting our house in
order and by the way Nikki Haley our
house is not in order yeah but do you
just say Okay Russia take take all of
Ukraine take whatever you want do
whatever you want and you know what if
that's gonna help Putin gain power and
Let Me Maybe maybe move on to another
country after who cares I run is that I
run 40 I run an issue or run an
insurance company with 45 000 insurance
agents okay hear me up I'm coming up
first I'm trying to be a good CEO okay
all of a sudden we're like on year two
three four whatever 2013 whatever 13 is
year four
and there's divorces Galore going on
everywhere in my company
Galore we're going to two of our best
guys phenomenal guys they're both going
through it okay and their wives one of
them both a husband and a wife ended up
staying here they're both doing very
well both of them are happy both that
are more financially free one has got
his own family she's got her own family
great and the other one is in a very
very good place just had a kid another
one on the way they're having great life
somehow we made it work where everybody
stuck around in the company it wasn't
easy
but in 2013-2014
one day I'm I'm at the hospital okay
after a full-on exhaustion I'm thinking
I'm dying okay I just came back from a
three-week trip I'm on the road I'm
doing what I'm doing and at night 12 30
2 clock go to the hospital and I'm at
the hospital 2 30 in the morning and the
doctor I'm like Doc what the hell is
going on with me says dude your heart is
strong as heck you're good you're good
he says you're just what what have you
been doing your body your dehydrated all
this if you're exhausted you need to
just rest
and told him he says well that's exactly
what's been happening you've been going
on three hours of sleep four hours to
sleep the last three weeks every night
I'm on the front of God knows one time
trying to save these marriages okay
you know what happened when I try to
save every one of these marriages with
the amount of time I put into them one
they feel like you're intruding too much
to get into their business between a
husband and wife which they almost were
like look we appreciate the help but we
appreciate the help great that's a
lesson and number two it's affecting
your own life
if you want to solve if America wanted
to solve everyone's problems worldwide
we would do it at the cost of going
bankrupt and America being just like the
other third world countries that are a
show now we are leaders you know
what leaders do we set the example we
set the tone we do our part we don't get
involved in every single conflict we do
our best to get involved in certain
conflicts but if we get involved in
every single conflict out there we don't
have a life and America forgets about
who you and I no I agree we matter to
America So when you say what should we
do where do you draw that line like
where do you draw a line like every is
it just America 100 like there has to be
a line somewhere where would you draw
that what if we didn't intervene in
World War II like okay I mean you could
make the same argument we shouldn't have
I didn't say every one of them so where
is that line drawn that I I understand
what you're saying but yeah you if you
sit there as a leader as a president of
the United States and you write out all
the issues that's going on okay let's
write out 50 issues that's going on
outside of America okay
some of them you're gonna have to say
hey
guess what NATO this is your problem
they're your neighbors they're not ours
okay you got to figure this thing out
okay sorry that you guys are going
through this you figured this thing out
then try to broker a deal with Putin Mr
Biden fly out to Russia or figure out a
way to have a meeting with them and
figure out a way to say why are we doing
this to do your part aside from that if
I want to get involved in a hundred
percent of all issues I'm not gonna have
a life and I'm ruining the country I'm
supposed to lead okay as a person that's
a CEO of a company if you're a CEO of a
company you're running you guys are
business owners you know the 3D printing
company and different things that you
guys have done in the past you got you
got to see all the company that you're
running okay then you have money in
mutual funds and stocks okay should you
be concerned about how Apple stock is
doing yeah you got a hundred thousand
dollars in delicious you got a million
dollars you should be concerned okay but
let's just say your business is worth 50
million dollars okay of your net worth
is tied to the 50 million dollar company
you got a million dollars in Apple stock
you got three hundred thousand dollars
in Tesla you got two hundred thousand
dollars here and there should you be
concerned about those companies sure but
more than a 50 million dollar company
that's taking care of your wife and kids
and a family in your net worth no no I
mean we're not though I mean but we are
how many billions have we given to
Ukraine how much have we spent on
different infrastructures
they're going to get everything they
need though they're going to get
everything they need when it's a natural
it's America bro it's now so changes
FEMA policies but I mean that takes more
than just Joe Biden snapping his fingers
no it doesn't the president can make an
executive order and come out and say
Hawaii the FEMA limits are set for the
instant payments here's what I want to
ask you though how often does that
happen to a state in America how often
what happened in Hawaii how often does
it happen as far as the instant FEMA
payments or I don't know
pretty frequently not to that level but
pretty frequently So to that level how
often has it happened since 1776 in
Hawaii how often the place where most
people go for honeymoon in Hawaii hasn't
it's never happened Okay so imagine the
president takes the lead and has a
meeting with senators and Congress men
and women all of them okay and he says
Hey I want to have an emergency meeting
right off the bat and he gets up there
and he says I'd like your support for us
for once go above whatever our FEMA
standards are and gets yeah but what
about Fort Myers why why shouldn't we
have gotten why shouldn't Kentucky have
gotten it why shouldn't Puerto Rico
gotten that same amount of money per
household that lost their entire house I
will tell you I am more supportive of us
taking care I think the American people
would be more noble to say I support
that more than I support the UK but who
who are the ones who want to defund FEMA
or reduce the funding and females
typically the conservatives don't they
call that socialism when you am I
sitting here telling you about defunding
female words no but what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that every single home
that's lost because of natural disaster
whether it was under Biden Trump Obama
bushes they should get more than 500 to
700 dollars
instantly right they should why is a
person losing their home in Hawaii
I'm really not you're not you're gonna
bring it back how you're deflecting you
want me to bring you back to tell you
how you're deflecting go ahead the
comparisons is not Fort Myers and Hawaii
you're deflecting my comparison as
Hawaii and Ukraine yeah and absolutely
I'm agreeing with you for Hawaii should
get more money but this isn't something
that's new I mean I know it isn't it is
new though identify this then go to the
next one okay right after we're dealing
with so much money we're given to
Ukraine to protect their border
yes we're giving money to Ukraine to you
said yes to protect their border is
Russia's invading them to take over
their land our border drugs dealers are
killing kids kids yeah it's not it's not
it's not enough how many kids died last
year from fentanyl how many kids died
last year from drugs that's coming
through from there and that mean to
compare what you're comparing government
compare a actual military incursion on
another country to refugees and people
coming here because they want whatever
better wait no no no no no it's not
different come do do legally yeah yeah
so but but the question becomes
what way of killing kids is more noble
okay is it more noble for me to kill the
kids with a bomb with a nuclear bomb or
with drugs a drug dealer coming in a
country killing a kid isn't
representative of the millions or
hundreds of thousands of refugees that
are just here so now where to get their
family a better life right categorize
what's a noble way to kill kids
what is your solution to the fentanyl
crisis it's it's most of it's coming
through ports of Entry people are
driving it through we should increase
security around the ports of Africa I I
I think that's a good idea I think when
you leave the gates as open as they have
where how many people came last year
what's the record-breaking number of
people that came in last year well no
it's not a hundred thousand No 109 000
were or or over fentanyl overdose well
overdose or or poisoning That's horrible
I mean I I mean well that's something
that needs to be done but just building
a wall is not gonna it might eliminate
one percent of that or five percent of
it no it's not one percent bro ninety
percent of the fentanyl that's caught
coming through ports of Entry right so
are there people walking over there 109
680 overdose death in 2020 to a highest
record in the calendar year this is last
year and the record was 2021 both under
this guy named Joe that you guys like
right
so if you say well Pat what do you want
to do about it the board is only going
to protect you know a certain percentage
of it if if you said 10 percent
of the borders 10 of the kids that would
protect what's 10 of 109 000. 11 000
kids would be here today but that's
making the argument that if you put up a
wall to prevent people from carrying it
over that is not going to be smuggled so
that's a same amount will be smart it's
a good start though yeah I mean there's
better okay let me ask you a question I
think there's better were you ever a
Playboy were you ever a Playboy when you
were younger or no who was the womanizer
would either one of you guys womanizers
or no who was good with the ladies
okay by the way let me ask you a
question okay I'm assuming it's you
because you're saying you're straight
you're not gay so you are okay all right
so if that's you
okay so let's go with that
um when you're 22 years old
and you meet a 19 year old girl what's a
target for you to know that it's going
to be easier for you to hook up with
this girl what's the easiest Target when
you learn about our family
that issues stamps in the wrong
places
there's no father there it's on okay so
now let me ask you this you go to his
house you go to her house
and she says here's my dad and the dad
shows up how you doing that good how you
doing doing good
and wife comes in oh honey just relax
babe my husband just got out of jail
last month for you know and he's just
murdering the last boyfriend what do you
think you're going to do when you go
with a date with that girl when you
think about your typical move of putting
your hands around her back and then the
popcorn you slip up you miss the popcorn
accidentally and then you're like oh I'm
so sorry oops you're like no I'm gonna
Target the popcorn right what are you
gonna do you're gonna be a little bit
more selective ain't you when you're
careful with that so what I'm saying to
you here is as a guy who's been married
15 years so prior to that I was single I
understand what it is when I see
opportunities so do you it's the Natural
Instinct men we have perfect
so child molester says who got arrested
at the time they said the number one
target when we're targeting kids
is if there's not a father there if
there's no faith there I can molest that
kid and take it he's telling you in the
interview I don't know if you've seen
this interview he's saying how to do
it's absolutely you got to watch it
since you got two kids you just gotta
watch it what's the point
no the board is not going to prevent 100
of it no putting more security down
there's going to prevent 100 of it no
arresting sanction getting rid of these
people in sanctuary City that's causing
what's going on in New York that New
York is saying no we don't follow the
government's laws when we arrest them we
have to catch and release and we're
going to do whatever we want to do but
hey can you guys send us some money I
need some help I absolutely think you
need more security there I just don't
think the wall is the best answer I
think there's technology you can use I
think you think I don't think a wall
from from one seed to the other sea
you're gonna have to seize private land
like I I'm against the wall because I
think that in certain areas you could
have fencing or walls but there's other
Technologies you can use you can
increase security around the ports of
Entry maybe stop more drugs we've all's
been the oldest way of keeping people
yes 2023 your house do you have your
places open on the outside like what are
you doing I have camera I have cameras
that's what I mean guess what let's get
the walls let's get the security let's
get all of it
all I'm saying to you is all I'm saying
to you is
so many of our establishment
pro-military industrial complex
politicians from the left and the right
support protecting the borders of
Ukraine how about we start with
protecting borders of America first and
then it doesn't have to be first though
that is first we can't no America is
first your family is protecting Ukraine
is putting America First no it's not
okay tell me this no what happens if
Putin decides to take a NATO Nation what
happens what happened world war three
well let me ask you this reporting to
Article Five uh yeah yeah one country
according to Article Five they have to
all attack right okay great but who
caused that who caused it because if
Putin takes NADA yeah who caused that I
would say it's Putin who calls this
you're going to blame NADA Putin caused
that okay so so let me ask you a
question uh when did when did the NATO
get started
first time Dad 12 countries that were
part of it right and then every year
they've recruited more and more and more
I think recently they just had Finland
that joined I think there are 31 right
now give or take I think if you can look
at to see how many members it is I think
it is 31. all right they go 31 members
today okay
and have you noticed the original
countries that joined NATO were more Far
West and gradually they're getting
closer and closer and closer to who to
Russia what happened the whole purpose
of the NATO was to defend against two
Soviet Union the fear communism all of
that stuff that's how it got started to
protect because they were being
aggressive when did Soviet Union Fall
in 91. what are we doing with NATO the
France walked away from NATO I think in
66 and then they came back in 2009 I
think they're the only ones that walked
away and came back so Russia's kind of
sitting there saying hey NATO some would
say NATO's also gets credit for unifying
China against Russia against Iran
against potentially now Saudi against
all these against India against Brazil
NATO gets credit for that as well don't
we give credit to Nato for that that
credit goes to Nato right If You're
Gonna Keep recruiting other countries
you think my ass is going to sit there
and nothing isn't that good for America
to do what to help NATO grow why because
it's part it's their allies we're
they're going to protect us to the point
of all because who's the enemy who is
the enemy of NATO gross who's the enemy
I mean you could say China could be a
potential enemy we don't have it I
wouldn't say we have a specific enemy
now but China
since you guys are about asking
questions is it fair to say that NATO
groin is what caused China Russia and
Iran to unite to get closer
I'm sure it has and which of those
countries hate us the most
who hates us the most I would say China
who holds you think Iran loves it you
think Iran wakes up in the morning
saying we love you we love Americans
yeah but are you saying that if NATO
didn't grow Russia wouldn't be
encroaching on other land I don't think
I don't think I do that again if NATO
didn't grow do you think that Russia
would not be encroaching in Ukraine or
elsewhere I don't think that would be I
think it'll grow in is forcing him to do
something I think NATO is pro-war I
think NATO wants to see the way the way
they've created their treaty and Article
5 forcing that if you attack one or more
members the
well it makes every nation in NATO
stronger that way I mean I mean why was
NATO formed because of Soviet Union and
Soviet Union fellow 91. right and right
after World War II a few years after
World War yeah yeah so like imagine
going back then and and telling the
found whoever created NATO there's the
various countries that
another country invaded a country close
to Nato and this is what what's
happening what do you think they would
say do you want to go back and say 2 000
years ago who the enemy of the Assyrians
were let's make sure
on one side you're arguing what's best
for America and what's best for America
is that yeah NATO gets stronger so
that's I mean that's my view so how many
friends of yours are married uh most of
them okay so whose marriage is more
important to work out yours are theirs
do you see where I'm going when I keep
going back to this so what if all of a
sudden all of your marriages your
friends stop going through a divorce do
you drop your marriage to try to save
every one of their marriages is that
what you're supposed to do no but if if
their marriage impacts your marriage in
some way it's worth helping say this to
what extent though to
if you asked no it's not trust me I've
spent more hours on trying to save
marriages with my business because you
know
um it's you just have to be in a model
to see what I'm talking about thousands
and thousands of hours of going through
this yes it's necessary but not at the
cost of what you're doing okay you
should be healthy my priority should be
to take care of my health and then to
tell you yesterday I'm getting my suit
uh what do you call it uh right and the
guy that comes and does my sister what
happened to your weights you lost four
four inches on your ways nice I'm like
damn kind of looking at this that's
pretty cool what's going on here uh well
guess what I July of 2019 is the last
time I had soda and I stopped having
breakfast five months ago I eat
breakfast once a week and it's my
favorite meal I have breakfast on
Sundays I don't need breakfast and my
breakfast is now I start off with maybe
a protein thing but I don't eat the big
breakfast I would eat in the morning and
all this change lost four inches I'm
down to 235 238 I feel good that's what
worked for me now me telling you that
story and then showing you how to do it
and encouraging you how to do it then
you go do it instead of me spending the
last four months to try to get your
waist to get smaller I mean do you
realize how ludicrous that argument is
America First America America's first
yes America's first America's first
great then if America's first
let's address Michael Jackson say this
in a song see that that's where I think
we differ is that man in the mirror no
he says if you want to make the world a
better place
take a look at yourself yeah that's man
is that what it is yeah of course yeah
America America's interest in the mirror
right now make that change America's
interest is
looking great make that change America's
interest in what's good for America
isn't only what's within our borders you
would agree right
like trade with China there's yeah it's
called foreign policy totally get it but
okay let me just get to the heart of the
matter here guys because I feel like
we're you guys both have actually valid
points but you know how they say follow
the money FTM so
one of the great things that uh you know
we can learn from uh the past is not to
repeat them well what you know to give
kudos to Trump he has not gotten us into
any
just endless spending Wars nonsensical
Wars
um so kudos to that but I understand you
know I I've said publicly the record we
can't just not do anything about Ukraine
we are part of NATO but the the question
is how much so I have questions for you
guys and I'll let Pat answer as well
how much money can we dedicate to
Ukraine we how much trillions did we
give to Afghanistan for nothing so is
the answer zero is the answer trillions
what's the answer because you can go
back and forth level involvement but the
actual substantive issue is how much so
how much money and how much time should
we spend in Ukraine well I think that's
it again impossible question for any of
us to answer uh I think that we should
Adam's trying to be the voice of reasons
like he's trying to I appreciate it take
control as if I need Adam's help to
really hold things together I'm not
asking for help I'm asking for go ahead
are you are you letting the zero is the
number let's let's see this is actually
a good question and I understand if
you're saying we don't have a real
answer to it you know as a finance guy
he's coming from a place of what
percentage of money should we have given
to us what we do we gave three trillion
would it have been okay with 100 billion
200 billion what we did with the
Afghanistan or in Ukraine go ahead so so
I I'd say from my point of view as long
as we can keep American soldiers out of
Ukraine well as long as we can do that
without and or out of Ukraine or out of
war in general like if if we can prevent
a World War III or we can prevent things
from escalating the point where we need
feel like we need to send U.S soldiers
overseas to fight in a war I think
that's the map and I mean of course not
like so billions a day right no not
blank check but I think within reason I
don't I can't calculate what what that
is you know I don't know I would say
like like giving them money and trying
to come up with some sort of treaty or
agreement between the countries I feel
that money is buying time so we can do
that I hope that they're working on
something uh do I know if something's
possible I don't know I don't know
what's going through Putin's head I
don't know what's going through zelinski
said I think I think Pat's point I think
I think it's zero money I think what Pat
said is having a leader that's strong
enough and has the balls to go to open a
dialogue and talk with the guy to not
have something like this happen and have
instead of having a guy that's just like
it's pooing he's evil in price like
blaming everything on Brewing I say zero
money right I mean they have enough
money at this point we just need
somebody to be able to like think about
where's the dialogue between Joe Biden
and our our Administration this
Administration we're proven there isn't
it's just he's the evil Batman you know
he wants to start a world war three and
that's it we have to support them
endless support to Ukraine whatever they
want there needs to be a happy Meetup do
you I don't think you're saying zero
I am more closer to zero than I have
about this but what what about like if
China was to take Taiwan do you feel the
same like we should completely stay out
well I'll let me let me give my argument
for both and then you can push back
um for me you know last month July 11th
of 2023 NATO members uh uh came out and
voiced their opinions about Expediting
the process for Ukraine to be part of
NATO you know what that they're pretty
much same with that well you know what
they're saying with that what they're
saying is Article Five yeah like no yeah
I agree I don't know if people
understand like they're trying to say
like it that that decision is trying to
say guys that's how World War III yeah
so so now to the skeptical audience who
is anti-establishment audience to people
that like the Kennedys of the world the
people that like the trumps of the world
the people that like the rfks of the
world some parts of is the people that
like these guys that are
anti-establishment they're sitting there
saying why would you guys want world war
three well a lot of military
defense contracts and Raytheon and
Northrop Grumman and General Dynamics
and boinking all this up okay yeah all
right cool I got you there's a lot of
money to be made there perfect now
the the other side from The
Establishment could say no that's
exactly how to protect Ukraine because
if Ukraine becomes part of NATO now
Russia knows if they attack that's
article five oh okay so now you've got
all these missiles pointing at Russia
okay from all these different military
bases okay for them there are missiles
but they're in that time I think from
Poland Germany if I'm getting some of
these rights Spain I don't know some
randomly in some countries and
Russia's sitting there saying do I look
like an idiot to you
like do I look like a too what are
you guys doing what do you want to do
you guys claim you want peace this is
your way of getting peace yeah I don't
know about this okay so you know the
other argument is Ukraine the amount of
Natural Resources they have and and the
political beliefs they're very important
to the world they provide a lot of
different things to everybody no one's
really spending a lot of time talking
about that that to me is a logical
approach of an argument to take and say
hey we need Ukraine because of XYZ
Russia's argument is going to be Ukraine
is Russia and this is what happened you
know the Warsaw whatever he's going to
take that angle China Taiwan is
I I almost feel China is watching this
case study with what's going on with
Russia and you know to see what's going
to happen there I think taiwan's a
slightly different argument of our
involvement to go there or not to go
there if I would much rather do the
following here's much rather way for me
to do business with you
you know this is how I work if you're a
an employee with me or a salesperson
with me or a partner of mine and you
leave and we're no longer together
I say look
in this relationship I'm not going to do
anything to hurt you the only one in
charge here to hurt this relationship is
you you know why why because
I'm going to support whatever you want
to do go get them but if you steal
clients if you go do this if you steal
people from this if you do any of this
stuff you're telling people publicly
that you're against me now you have a
problem with me no problem and we'll let
the lawyers and whoever needs to do
their thing handle it I've been on both
sides I'll trust that side and you're
publicly saying I don't value this
relationship okay
perfect what if we come up and we meet
with Russia or we meet with China we
keep them close in a relationship-wise
not a relationship where it's like we
become best friends but look we send you
a lot of business you send us a lot of
business let's just be straight up
you can't do anything with Taiwan here's
why if you do you're gonna force me to
put these tariffs on you and it's going
to hurt the business and you're going to
force me to tell NATO to not do business
with you it's really going to hurt a lot
of things that you're doing
I can take that approach with Russia and
or haven't we already kind of taken that
approach with Russia and not sanctions
not Biden Trump did and it worked there
was no attacks under Ukraine it was
given there's there's still sanctions
against Russia right the approach Trump
took was a different approach than the
approach we're taking right now the
approach Trump took is let's sit down
let's talk and let's figure out a way to
make this work and it was a peaceful
world for those four years yeah but the
situation is different now with Russia
yeah because Biden Biden made it easy
for uh
he said it at one point I said he said
I'll welcome a small incursion he
actually invited them to attack bro they
want war they want war it's a money
machine
how many weapons are you gonna sell if
nuclear bombs start going off well if
nuclear bombs are going off 70 of the
world is done exactly just so you know
70 is down down immediately and it's not
going to take a long time if this
happens because it's going to be a
reactionary thing so you know you're
you're playing with fire NATO is playing
with fire they are and some people could
say so you mean to tell us we leave
Ukraine alone is that the right thing to
do if that means we can prevent a World
War III from happening the answer is
actually yes yeah but I think others
would argue that not getting involved in
Ukraine could lead to World War III as
well and so and I mean and maybe we'll
never be alone because if there's a
nuclear war there is no podcast we're
doing a podcast with rocks and we're
looking at each other Florida might
actually still be America I think we'd
be spared and run by the way before
there's a Time guys please subscribe to
the podcast we're going to be here for a
little while longer before anything yeah
thank you what is this Robbie just put
up I think that we are going to see uh
is that Russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does if there's one thing if it's a
minor incursion uh uh uh and then we end
up having a fight about that's when
Biden came in he was like well it's
basically well yeah not not this
and then after this they invaded you
know I mean fellas so so what do you
what do you guys do for people to be to
find what projects are you guys working
on right now uh so we're on Twitter
crassenstein my last name he's Ed crass
and uh we have a podcast crashing cast
uh everything's on Twitter though uh so
basically if you want to find us just go
to Twitter it's not Twitter
yeah so Rob if you can put the links
below for people to find out of the
debate the GOP debate who are you guys
impressed with was it you know like I
say Nikki Haley number one who's number
two I I think Haley did good uh Vivek he
disappointed me I was actually kind of
getting behind him a little bit at least
from a GOP perspective uh I think Haley
did good I also I mean I like Chris
Christie I think he is funny but those
on the right aren't gonna happen who was
last who was last on your list
I mean I'd say what was the governor of
North Dakota
robotic yeah I think he's robotic like I
I really thought that Santa's was gonna
have a chance when he first announced
but I feel like he's going down
as as Floridians I think I mean Trump
trump brought him down yes and and your
your uh guesstimation of who's going to
be the president 2024 you're thinking
it's going to be Biden or you think
somebody that needs me Biden I think
it's going to be Biden I I wish that
Democrats would nominate someone younger
but that's not going to happen ideal
situation who would you want would you
want like a news summary
Michelle's not gonna run right you never
know sleeper no not like the Hail Mary
okay all right well gank it's been great
having you on tomorrow appreciate you
guys for coming out thanks it was great
thank you it's always I respect anytime
guys are willing to come and sit down
and talk and you know respectful you
debate and do all of that I salute you
not a lot of people want to do that it
says a lot about the fact that you're
willing to go out there and sit down and
have these conversations thanks for
having us I got a lot of respect for
people like that so I appreciate you
guys for doing that Rob tomorrow we have
uh Michael Flynn General Michael Flynn
oh really tomorrow General Michael okay
so tune in tomorrow 9 A.M General
Michael Flynn take care everybody bye
bye bye
Patrick David here from Valley team and
pbd podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to skill their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
property skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the obsessed
they're scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit they're
content they're walking around saying
life is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow on a season like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's gonna
talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yet this is my recommendation
to I never went to conferences when I
was coming up by myself I always went
with a spouse with a business partner or
running mate because I only have a lens
on what I see every night afterwards we
would sit there and say what was your
biggest takeaway so get yourself your
spouse your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
[Music]
[Applause]
all right